there have been lots of rumors that
Kathleen Kennedy head of lucasfilm has
been fired but what is actually the
truth welcome to psycheck your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so around a month ago the room is really
started to get very intense that
Kathleen Kennedy head of lucasfilm
currently and a person that has worked
with Steven Spielberg threatened to try
a career has been involved in producing
some of the biggest and highest grossing
movies of all time has been fired from
lucasfilm following very poor results
since well basically everything
lucasfilm has touched in the last 10
years but particularly Indiana Jones and
the dial of destiny that is actually
currently destined to be one of the
biggest flops really ever or definitely
in recent Years anyway the rumor
actually became even more serious than
that when it was alleged that she was
actually being investigated for
embezzlement now that is a serious
accusation to make even for the internet
to suggest that she had been embezzling
money from lucasfilm
I can actually tell you that apparently
that is not true but there is a nugget
of truth to it I can also tell you
apparently that it is not true that
she's been fired but that does not
necessarily mean that she isn't leaving
lucasfilm shortly so what is the actual
truth well apparently there has been a
lot of pressure on Kathleen Kennedy
since Bob Iger took over back as CEO of
Disney they are not happy with some of
the decisions that have been made in the
last few years and they're not happy
with the current direction plan for
lucasfilm including obviously the
biggest franchise Star Wars they have
already rejigged a lot of the Star Wars
calendar for the next couple of years
and made some big sweeping changes and
Kathleen Kennedy has been involved in
that but apparently Bob Iger has asked
her to step aside so she has not been
fired she has been asked to potentially
leave
apparently around the water coolers at
Disney and obviously in The Wider
Hollywood Community this has been the
Talk of the Town people have been
talking about this almost as much as
they've been talking about the strikes
it is actually a big deal considering
Kathleen Kennedy's pedigree that she is
going to be moving on from lucasfilm now
this process of finding somebody to
replace it could potentially take months
so I don't expect anything to happen
really quickly
but why are we getting the rumors that
we're getting because there is a little
bit of Truth to both of them but then
they've just been massively exaggerated
by the internet you naughty internet
exaggerating things
the truth is behind the embezzlement or
rumor that actually there has been
internal investigation at lucasfilm and
actually across other areas of Disney
about mismanagement of budgets that is
not necessarily aimed even remotely at
Kathleen Kennedy and there is no element
that that could be a criminal charge
the rumor basically was that she was
going to quit to avoid criminal charges
that apparently isn't true
so there has been an investigation at
Lucasville and other parts of the white
Disney business
about
mismanagement of budget and basically
spending money badly that actual fact is
then turned into the rumor because there
are certain people who really don't like
Kathleen Kennedy particularly on the
internet there are hate clickers and
YouTube channels that blame Kathleen
Kennedy for Star Wars movies they don't
like or Indiana Jones maybe they didn't
like and they're targeting that directly
her feet now that is yeah a little bit
fair and a little bit not fair but
at the end of the day the book stops
with her she is the boss and that's why
I get the new head of Disney is asking
us to step aside
so the rumor about being fired again has
come from the same thing because it has
a nugget of Truth she has been asked to
step aside they will be looking for a
new head of lucasfilm so again an
exaggerated version of the actual truth
but guys again in the comments tell me
what you think is Disney doing the right
thing they're shaking up Marvel
massively they're shaking up lucasfilm
massively they need to change the
direction of this ship because I would
argue Disney hasn't actually done
anything really any good for at least a
couple of years now
bang on and correct and desperately
wanting to shake up the people at the
top because they need to go in a
different direction do you actually
blame Kathleen Kennedy for a lot of the
mistakes that have happened over the
last few years or is it just seem to be
Disney as a whole that can't make a
decent movie at the moment
I mean I would argue Marvel have made
way bigger turkeys than Lucas
maybe well guys get into the comments
and tell me exactly what you think if
you are new to the Channel please don't
forget to like subscribe hit that Bell
notification share the video wherever
the hell you want also you can go to
patreon.com scitracker most of our new
videos appear first and for some more
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]